that's right across the Lebanese Syrian
border
I stopped pulled out my camera because I
had resolved that the entire time I was
the Middle East that I was going to keep
a detailed photographic record of all my
landscapes and have a real collection of
Geographic photographs as it turned out
I took about 20,000
when I when I I saw the
description of this photo it just had a
church on the outskirts of our deal and
when I saw the photo I I couldn't
believe it
I'm an iraqi-american but my parents are
both Iraqi born bred and instilled the
ideals and the idea of this country in
our head this Garden of Eden I was very
aware of this monastery my entire life
that it existed and that one day I was
gonna go visit it my great-grandparents
kept having daughters and they wanted a
son so they went to this monastery named
after a st. Behnam and they prayed to
st. Behnam and said please give us a boy
please give us a boy and my grandfather
madam was born and they dressed him up
like a girl when they for it when I took
him back because the evil spirits that
were guaranteeing that my great-grandma
didn't have a son would be tricked
sadly March 2015
Isis blew it up and my whole family was
was distraught It was as if my
grandfather had died again
these photos give a lot of insight into
these artifacts because so many of them
are destroyed and were destroyed by Isis
recently for Americans I think it's
really useful to look at these photos
and see like this is the beginning of
civilization one of the most ancient
lands of all time I mean we all care
about history and culture and which is
weird like you don't listen to Drake
you're you know going to cheesesteak
joint and Philly and be like this is
civilization but it is you know Syria is
known as the cradle of civilizations and
walking down the streets of sphere you
see a diverse mix of people you know you
see you can literally see the history
through the ages senior analysts and
activists Boehner is in Damascus the
last time I visited the city was 2011
and then I was detained and I had to
leave and I was never be able to stand
visit the city again I'm a Syrian
American I was born and raised in
Florida but I am originally from
Damascus in 2011 we were full of hope
after a few weeks from the uprising or
the revolution it evolved and they
invented something called the how would
you translate that the the flying
protest something like that which is
like three four minutes they they agreed
to go to that point and to pretend that
for example they are just walking or
eating it starts and everybody's
chanting and they are filming and and
then like two three minutes and they say
that's it
[Music]
we didn't think about this industrial
torture and and killing from the
government and we didn't expect that
we'll have one day something called Isis
for example those pictures are very
important to show so people when they
look at them they don't only see
buildings and stones but also they
realize that there are stories
associated to those places many places
in Turkey always had a shortage of water
we had an agreement among ourselves that
when the water came on we would all go
to the window in the courtyard and call
out sous-sous so that everybody could
run fill the bathtub this is one of the
strong memories in one of our family
stories we sometimes forget like like
teeth were like very different like
years ago and like when I look to these
photos
I remember ah like some parts of
Istanbul I had not been always like a
shopping mall of course I have lived on
my life in Istanbul two years ago I came
to United States to do my Master's you
should see this place now there like all
these like very chic breakfast places
cafes restaurants it creates like some
sort of class-based segregation in the
city for sure there is something lost
their Grand Bazaar is like this old
Ottoman Bazaar in Istanbul when you go
there it's like you want like few
centuries back it's a place that carried
that thing from the past but also like
trust from itself I mean I don't really
like Istanbul being little presenters
like I like a bridge between like East
and West it's like you can like show a
veiled woman is like the east of Turkey
and like a woman with like a miniskirt
is like the Western but it doesn't work
like that like you can't like
everybody's categories you lose
what actually is happening America likes
to focus on the juicy headlines of
violence and radical groups
I've been asked if from oil girls in my
back yards I ride camels to school I'm
being completely and genuinely serious
the Gulf countries have a lot to offer
in terms of how they prospered from
nomadic communities and pearl divers
accommodations were not then what they
are now Kuwait had one more or less
decent hotel but the walls of my room
were made out of cardboard I have to
laugh at the super super luxury hotels
that are there now I'm a Kuwaiti of
Palestinian origin I am born and raised
Kuwaiti from a large Queenie family in
terms of this picture if you were to
look at what it looks like today you'd
see like a lot more skyscrapers every
other Street you can see huge
skyscrapers and then a few corners away
you have old traditional houses you have
this stoop running through the middle of
the city and what's really amazing is
the youth actually built an extra sides
to the souk and they've called it somos
it's there's bone like burger joints and
pop-up stores these are showing me
images that for some reason maybe due to
technology weren't available for Kawai
T's to create themselves so you know we
don't necessarily have access to these
we're spend more time learning about
World War two in Europe than we do of
our own history so for me this is
amazing to see how far we've gone queit
has progressed so much even if we revert
to the way things were configured we're
not going
our claim to modernity Lebanon is an
example of a country that had difficult
times but has managed to have a society
which is inclusive and very open it and
free and that's rather unique in the
world let alone unique in the Middle
East
I am Lebanese and American and I grew up
in a Lebanon that was very open to the
world very vibrant it was called the
Paris of the Middle East but it had a
number of political problems and it
descended into a long civil war to see
the collapse of a state and the basic
order that you grew up in and thought
and took for granted being replaced by
people with guns in every neighborhood
setting up their own checkpoints seeing
friends of mine getting polarized
picking up guns and maybe shooting at
somebody who might have been a neighbor
and that's scary
since then we've had 26 years of
rebuilding in an inclusive democratic
society the massive demonstrations
what's known as the Cedar Revolution
happened around this statue in 2005
maybe more than a million
million and half people in a country of
4 million these moments when you know
citizens by their hundreds of thousands
who are all agreeing on one unifying
passion they really want something
different than the reality that they're
in
but those beautiful wishes are rarely
realized even if you take pictures of
Europe seven years ago you'd see
devastation civil war the Nazis genocide
you know but time moves on yes Middle
East is going through a very difficult
dangerous traumatic period but history
is about change that is about you know
phases and things developing it hasn't
been always this way and it's not always
going to be this way
you